thanks so much great to be here and
happy halloween belated halloween
everyone um
so i think the talk is going to be split
into two sections so i'll start by
spending like 10 minutes 15 minutes
chatting about transformers in general
um but i'm assuming most of you are
familiar with them and we can move on to
mpts which yannick and neil will be
presenting
so let's see
i'm gonna like
try to fly through
the transformer overview and maybe spend
a little bit
extra time on like the history of
transformers and maybe just tell the
story a little bit i think that might be
more interesting
so just in terms of the transformer
architecture
the two kind of things that it
introduced for the first time were
multi-head attention and self-attention
and then it combined those with fast
utter aggressive decoding so before the
transformer
pretty much everyone was using lstms um
and lcms with attention
um
i'll try to get into the difference of
self-attention multi-head attention
so originally you would have two
sequences and you would have a attention
module which would attend from the
source to the target
and so each token or each word in the
source sequence would get associated
with you know a soft approximation of
one element in the target sequence
um
and so you'd end up with something like
like this but with self-attention we did
away with the two separate sequences we
make them both the same
and so you're relating each element
within the sequence to another element
in the sequence
um
and so the uh
the idea here is that you're you're
learning a relationship of the words
within a sentence to the other words so
you can imagine something like
uh an adjective which is being applied
to a noun and so you want to relate that
adjective like the blue ball you want to
relate blue as referring to ball
so we're learning patterns within the
sequence interest sequence patterns
so sorry i gave this talk in kenya so
i'm using kiswahili here uh but
with multi-head attention the idea is
you have like each word represented by
an embedding which is in the depth
dimension here and then you have your
sentence of words
you split that up into a bunch of
different groups
so here i've chopped it depth wise into
four groups
you apply attention to each one of these
groups independently
and then when you get the result back
you concatenate them together and you're
back to your
uh you know model dimension
representation
so
what this lets you do is if each
attention has like each attention head
can now focus on learning one pattern
so maybe attention head one is learning
uh the relationship of adjectives to
nouns uh and the second attention head
can learn something different uh so this
lets us
learn like a hierarchy or a or a list of
different relationships
okay so that was self-attention
the uh
the other piece is fast auto repressive
decoding
um
and do i really want to go into this
okay i will so the the important thing
about this is that um
if you're doing normal auto aggressive
decoding what you do is you generate
your first token and now conditioned on
that first token you generate the second
and condition on the first two you
generate the third and so on and so
forth that's super slow right like it's
a loop applying this thing again and
again
and so what we can do instead
is we make an assumption
in the code that our model always
generates the right thing
um and we generate and then we generate
a prediction
uh
only one token ahead and so the way that
this looks is
you uh okay so
y
y hat here
um
sorry once again
input output so you have your like your
outputs which are y uh you have your
targets which are
y hat
and what you do is you feed in those
gold targets so that you don't need to
actually do this loop so instead of
assuming instead of having to generate
the first token feed it back into your
architecture generate a second token you
feed in the entire target sequence
and you just pretend that you generated
all the right tokens up to position k
and then you predict the k plus first
and you compute your loss on that
so in reality your model might have
generated you know at the beginning of
training
junk but you're getting a loss as if
your model had seen all the correct
tokens and is now just predicting the
next one this is a little bit subtle
but it's hugely impactful for training
speed
because all this can be done on parallel
in parallel and so it's actually what
makes
transformers so scalable
okay so in order to do this successfully
if you were just feeding in all of the
all the correct tokens
uh naively what would happen is your
model would just be able to
look forward in time
and cheat so you've put in all of your
true targets the things that you're
trying to get your model to predict
and so if that's what you're computing
your loss on you could just look forward
in time and say okay i'm just going to
grab that and we'd get zero error
trivially right because you've given it
all the right answers so what we have to
do inside the architecture is we need to
actually prevent
the attention mechanism from being able
to look at tokens that it shouldn't have
been able to see already
so the way that this looks is
you
create a mask on your attention
and
so sorry this is the example of like
doing a trivial attention if you don't
mask your attention properly
what it's going to do is it's just going
to look into the future just grab the
token that you're telling it to predict
and copy it over and so learn something
trivial something that doesn't actually
generalize and so what we do is we
actually prevent it from attending to
those tokens we prevent it from
attending into the future
for each position in the source sequence
we block out
everything that it shouldn't be able to
see everything into the future and then
as we move down we gradually unblock so
we can start to see into the past
um
so those are kind of like the two
the three major components of
transformers
the self-attention
the multi-head attention and then
deploying this gold targets decoding
this fast auto aggressive decoding
um
in terms of the story which might be a
little bit more interesting
um
so transformers i was an intern
with lukash kaiser at google back in
2017
and i was sitting next to gnome
and ashish was like a couple seats down
from us
um
and what's really incredible is that
essentially this entire project came
together in like three months
and it was done
so i showed up at google
uh noam had been working on
auto aggressive models um same thing
with like ashish and yakov and and nikki
and um
they'd just been kind of like exploring
the space figuring it out
uh and lukasz and i at the same time we
had been working on this framework
called tensor to tensor
which was like explicitly made for
multimodal learning auto aggressive
learning um
and
lukash is kind of like a master of
keeping track of everything that's
happening in the field and adopting it
and so within tensor to tensor
there were like these
there were like these kind of emerging
little things that maybe one paper had
been written about
and people were interested in like layer
norm
but it hadn't actually taken off yet
the warm-up in the learning rate
schedule
all of these little pieces were just
default
like on by default
um
and so when noam and dashish and nikki
and jacob
came over and adopted tensor to tensor
all of these things were just on by
default um and so a lot of people
when they look at the the transformer
paper it just seems like there's so many
like arbitrary
little things thrown in
and when now like in in present day
these have become standard for like a
lot of different
training algorithms like the learning
rate warm-up
um
the way that we did initialization
uh all of these pieces have just
become the norm but back then they had
like kind of just been introduced
um
and so
we uh
we spent a lot of time running ablations
trying to figure out like which were the
necessary pieces and what made it work
and if any of you have actually
tried training transformers and tried
like pulling out the learning rate warm
up um
or changing out of any of these little
pieces you'll see that it really does
break down optimization like it actually
really does
um hurt performance for instance like
removing the layer norms that type of
thing um
so i i always thought it was kind of
funny how
all of these random editions that lucas
had just like thrown in because he was
playing around with them turned out to
be crucial uh and they were just on by
default um
so anyway it was like three months i
remember
um
it all really started coming together
towards the end like just before the
nureps deadline
um
and i can still remember sitting in the
micro kitchen and a sheesh telling me
like i was just like i was a little
intern uh telling me like this is gonna
be such a big deal and i was like yeah
sure okay
i have no idea what's happening i i just
showed up um
and he was like no dude like this this
actually matters like you know we bumped
up blue three points and i was like sick
great anyway
um
and then i can remember on the night of
the deadline for nurips
it was like 2 am uh ashish
sheesh was the only one left at the
office and we were still like moving
around figures and like adjusting things
and then um i went to bed but she stayed
up and i slept in like this tiny little
phone booth
um
and then for the other paper that i was
submitting i forgot to press submit but
luckily
like some lady opened the door to the
phone booth and hit me in the head while
i was sleeping in the morning
and just before the deadline i got the
paper in and so
i owe it to that to that lady
uh for for submitting to nerves that
year but yeah anyway the i think the
crazy thing about transformers was that
it all came together in like three
months like most of the ideas happened
in that span and it was just like this
sprint towards the nerves deadline
um
i think a lot of the other members on
the team yaakov
they knew how important it was but for
me i was like
i don't know i i really did not
appreciate
uh the impact um
but in retrospect it's been amazing how
the community has kind of like come
together and adopted it
um
and i think most of that can be ascribed
to the ease of optimization it seems
like very robust to hyper parameter
choices so you don't need to like tune
the hell out of it spend a lot of time
tweaking little things
and the other side is it's like super
tailored to the accelerators that we run
on
um
so it's like very paralyzable
hyper efficient um and so it lends
itself to that kind of scaling law
effort that's that's really taken off in
in popularity
okay uh unless there are any
oh my questions
we're both excited so we just unmute it
at the same time
so cool
yeah so that's that's my section if
there's any questions happy to answer
them otherwise
uh let's get into npt's mpts are like i
think um
there's such a nice next level
abstraction of the architecture so
you've probably seen the trend of
transformers getting applied to new
domains
um
first into vision and video and audio
um
but this is kind of like cutting back to
an even more abstract
level
um like i think tabular data yeah i
don't know i'll let yannick and neal
take over from here but uh i think mpt
is a pretty sick pretty sick project
thanks aidan for the introduction um
thanks all for the invitation we're very
happy to be here and
neil and i are now going to tell you
about our
self-attention between data points paper
where we introduce introduce the
non-prometric transformer architecture
we'll start with a little bit of
motivation move on to explaining the
architecture in detail and show you the
experiments this is more or less a step
through of the paper but maybe you know
with a little bit of extra insight here
and there
all right as promised motivation and a
brief summary
so
we'll start by thinking about something
that we don't often think about and that
is that from cnns to transformers most
of supervised deep learning relies on
parametric prediction
so what that means is that we have some
self-training data and we want to learn
to predict the outcomes y from the
inputs x for this we set up some model
with tunable parameters theta
then we optimize these parameters to
maximize predictive likelihoods on a
training set or you know equivalently we
minimize some loss
and then after training we have this
optimized set of parameter theta and
then at test time we just put these into
the model and use these parameters to
predict on novel test data
and so crucially here our prediction at
test time only depends on these
parameters right it's it's
parametric also that means that given
these parameters the prediction is
entirely independent of the training
data
and so
why would we want to do parametric
prediction
well it's really convenient because all
that we've learned from the training
data can be summarized in the parameters
and so prediction time we only need
these final parameters and we do not
need to store the training data which
might be really really large
on the other hand we usually have models
that already predict for a bunch of data
in parallel right think of mini batching
and modern architectures
and actually things like batch norm
already make these data interact
and so our thinking here was that if
we've got all of this data in
paralleling ways there's no reason not
to make use of it and so
more a bit grounder we kind of challenge
parametric prediction as the dominant
paradigm in deep learning and so we want
to give models the additional
flexibility
of using the training data directly when
making predictions
and so a bit more concretely
we introduced the non-parametric
transformer architecture and this is
going to be a general deep learning
architecture
meaning we can apply it to a variety of
scenarios
npt's will take the entire data set as
input whenever possible
and npts then crucially learn to predict
from interactions between data points
and to achieve this we use multi-head
self-retention
that as agent has introduced us to
has just really established itself as a
general purpose layer for
reasoning we also take another thing
from the the nlp community and we use a
stochastic masking mechanism
and we use that to tell npts where to
predict and also to regularize the
learning task a bit
and lastly of course we hope to convince
you that this ends up working really
really well and that this kind of simple
idea of learning to predict from the
other data points of the input from the
training points of the input and stop
working rather
sorry and so very briefly summarizing
what we've heard already
a
we input into nptc tie data set
and then b let's say for the purpose of
this slide here we only care about
predicting the orange question mark in
that green row
and then we can compare npt's to
parametric prediction right so a
classical deep learning model would
predict this target value only from the
features of that single green input to
do that it would use the parameters
theta those would depend on whatever
training data we've seen and so on but
at test time we only look at that single
row for which we care about the
prediction
in contrast npts predict an explicit
dependence on all samples in the input
they can look beyond that single green
datum of interest and look at all other
songs that are there and consider their
values for prediction so this presents
an entirely different way of thinking
about how we learn predictive mechanisms
and somebody on twitter called this k n
2.0 which
we would have not written in the paper
but maybe is kind of a nice way of
thinking about how mpgs can learn to
predict
so of course non-parametric models are a
thing already we didn't invent them at
all and
i defined them here as prediction in
explicit dependence on the training data
which is certainly what mpgs do
classical examples like gaussian
processes k-nearest neighbor kernel
methods those might be familiar to you
and there exists also efforts to combine
the benefits of non-prometrics and
representation learning
in a similar fashion to how we did it in
entities
however um
these approaches are usually limited in
some sense in comparison temperatures
right they're often
kind of motivated from the statistics
community a bit more they often require
some finicky approximate inference
schemes are limited in the interactions
they can learn or things like that and
so
we really think mpts present
maybe the most versatile and most widely
applicable of these non-prometric
prediction approaches but that's
something we explicitly wanted to have
we wanted to have something that's
really easy to use plug and play works
in a ton of scenarios and uh works
really well
and so with that uh i'd hand over to
neil who's going to tell you about the
non-parametric transformer architecture
in all of its details
yeah you also have one question
go ahead
yes yes
uh hi so could you please go back to the
previous slide
the very previous slide yeah yes this
slide yeah so
in terms of the problem definition i
think it's quite similar to some might
learning problem which basically there's
a mapping from a data point on the data
set to some predictions
so could you please suggest any
differences between
your problem setting and math learning
problem settings i can't really
figure out any differences between these
two problems
well
i i think it really depends on the the
framing that you want to have right so i
would say meta learning would be when i
try to predict over multiple data sets
so when i try to predict some when i try
to learn some sort of prediction model
or i can just plug in a different data
set and it will automatically or almost
automatically give me new predictions on
this different data distribution
but that's not what we do at all right
we're training a single model for a
fixed data set
and so this is why i wouldn't really
call that meta learning because we're
doing
we're trying to print on the same tasks
that all the supervised deep learning or
any supervised machine learning method
is trying to predict well on
consuming you use kind of same test site
to
test your trainer model right
i mean
i mean like uh
so
so so basically in my learning we're
gonna test on different kind of meta
test sets but in your case you just
wanna
use a test set which is similar to the
distribution
yeah sorry of your training set right
yeah absolutely so we explore data set
distribution shift a bit i think it's a
really interesting scenario i think meta
learning uh different data sets is also
an interesting scenario right when you
have this model where you could just
push in different datasets but for the
scope of this paper it's very much
training set test sets they come from
the same distribution and we're just um
trying to do supervised learning in a
standard setting
cool thank you
thank you for the question
yeah and i would chime in um a couple
additional things i guess um so at least
from what i understand from the problem
definition of metal learning i think the
aim is more
perhaps being able to perform well on a
new data set with a relatively small
number of additional gradient steps on
that data set um so i think there's some
interesting ways that you could actually
consider applying npts in a metal
learning type setting um and so we'll
get into this a little bit more but for
example
you know there might be ways to
essentially add in a new data set um so
let's suppose we've trained on a bunch
of different data sets we now add in a
new data set uh we can perhaps do some
sorts of kind of
zero zero shot um meta learning
basically where there's no need for
additional gradient steps because we're
basically predicting kind of similar to
how you might do prompting nowadays in
nlp literature um
anyways yeah i think we'll get into some
more details
uh just don't chime in on that
uh i don't think that every metal
learning
algorithm i think the ones that you
describe right now are like optimization
based but they're also black box ones
like you don't need to
further i think the main difference
seems to be that there is like one task
versus multiple tasks for metal learning
yeah i think i think so too i think that
the like main yeah the frame the main
framing question is whether or not
there's multiple data sets
cool
okay awesome if there's no other
questions i'll dive a bit more into the
architecture
awesome
so there's three key components to npts
i'm going to first state them at a high
level and then we'll go through each of
them in more detail
so first of all we take the entire data
set all data points as input um so for
example at test time the model is going
to take as input both training and test
data
and we
approximate this with mini batches for
large data
we apply self-attention between data
points so for example at test time
uh we model relationships amongst
training points amongst test points and
between the two sets
and then finally um we have this masking
based training objective uh it's a
birth-like stochastic masking and the
key point is that we actually use it on
both features as well as on training
targets and we'll get into why that um
kind of leads to an interesting
predictive mechanism later
so to start with this idea of data sets
as input
there's two things that compose the
input to npt um it's a full data set in
the form of a matrix x and a masking
matrix m
and so yannick has described this
dataset matrix a little bit uh we
basically have data points as rows uh
the columns are attributes and each
attribute shares some kind of semantic
meaning among all of its data points um
so say for example you're just doing
single target classification or
regression
the last column would be the target and
the rest of the matrix would be input
features so for example the pixels of an
image
we also have a masking matrix so let's
say
you know we're thinking about mass
language modeling the mass tokens will
just tell us where we're going to
conceal words uh and where we're going
to backpropagate a loss
um we do a similar type of thing here
where we use this binary mass matrix to
specify which entries are masked
and
the goal is to predict mass values from
observed values
um i see that there was a question about
uh handling inputs with different
lengths um
in in the data sets we've considered um
we've we'll we'll get into it in the
results section but it's mostly been
sort of tabular and image data where the
lengths for each of the data points is
the same but it would work just like
padding that would be a reasonable way
to to go about that
um and there's also kind of an
interesting yep go for a unique
just to add to that i'm not sure if
length depends
prefers uh refers to columns or to rows
right rows we don't care about how many
rows length padding or something would
be an option
yeah my question was about column
exactly so that that makes sense lots of
things
yeah i mean that goes along with the
whole meta learning discussion is i
think if we wanted to adapt to data sets
that have a different number of data
data points per data set
you know we can take advantage of the
fact that self-attention is kind of uh
okay with that
cool
um
so continuing on
uh left to discuss here is um basically
how we do the embedding uh so to put
this more explicitly we have this uh
data matrix that has n data points uh
it's called x and uh it also has d
attributes and we have this binary mass
matrix m uh we're going to stack them
and then we're going to do a linear
embedding
so specifically we're doing
the same linear embedding independently
for each data point we're learning a
different embedding for each attribute
we have a positional encoding on the
index of the attributes because we don't
really care about say being equivalent
over the columns if it's tabular data
you of course want to treat all these
kind of heterogeneous columns
differently
and then finally we have an encoding on
the type of column so whether or not
it's continuous or categorical
and that ends up giving us this input
data set representation
that is dimensions n by d by e
the second key component of npts is a
tension between data points
so to do that
we first take this representation we
have and flatten to an n by d times e
representation
so basically we're treating each of
these d times e size rows as if it's a
token representation
we're actually going to just accomplish
this operation using multi-head
self-retention um you know we've
reviewed this a lot but the nice thing
is that
we know from language modeling if we
stack this multiple times we can model
these higher order dependencies and here
they're
between data points and that's really
the key draw of this architecture um
there's been other kind of instances of
people using attention versus for
similar sorts of things so for example
like attentive neural processes um a lot
of times
they've sort of used just a single layer
as kind of a representational lookup and
we believe that this actually ends up
limiting expressivity and that by
stacking this many times you can learn
more complex uh relationships between
the data points
we also have some questions
i also can go ahead first oh cool uh
thanks i have a question about like how
you guys do the embedding is there
always like arteries like convolutional
filters or
like linear layers like what is the type
of embedding that you guys use yeah so
i'm attempting to go back to the slide i
think it's not not very happy with me
right now but um yeah so for
for tabular data we did um just linear
embeddings actually so we um
you know we could get into like i guess
details of futurization for categorical
and continuous but it's literally like
say for categorical you know you do a
one-hot encoding and then you learn this
embedding that is specific to that
attribute um and then for numerical i
believe it was just standard normalizing
um for the image data we did end up
using um
a resnet18 encoder for c410 um however i
think that i mean we'll discuss that a
bit later in results but um
that embedding is a bit arbitrary
you can sort of do whatever the key part
of the architecture is the attention
between data points so it's
in in terms of how you actually want to
embed each attribute it's kind of up to
you
thanks
i think uh you had a question
uh same question asked victorious
awesome
cool um so
uh here we have a tension between data
points done uh so we can also do this
attention between attributes
so uh we reshape back to this n by d by
e representation and then we can just
apply self-attention independently to
each row
in other words to a single data point
and the intuition for why we would kind
of do this nested type idea where we
switch between attention between data
points and attention between attributes
is just
we're trying to learn better per data
point representations for the between
data point interactions
this is literally just normal
self-attention as you'd see in language
modeling or image classification
the attributes are the tokens here
and finally we just rinse and repeat
so what are we actually getting out of
this um to summarize we're learning
higher order relationships between data
points
we're learning transformations of
individual data points
and then importantly npt is equivariant
to a permutation of the data points
this basically just reflects the
intuition that the learned relationships
between the data points should not
depend on the ordering in which you
receive them or in which you observe
your data set
the third key component of npt's is a
masking based training objective
so recall that what we're trying to do
is we're trying to predict missing
entries from observed entries and those
mass values can be both features or
targets
um so again the classic use say mass
language modeling is to do
self-supervised learning on a sequence
of tokens uh which you could think of as
just having features in our setting um
ours is a bit different
in that we do stochastic feature masking
to mass feature values with a
probability p sub future and then we
also do this masking of training targets
um with this probability p sub target
so if we write out the training
objective
we are just taking a weighted sum
of the negative log likelihood loss from
targets as well as from features
and of course at test time we're only
going to mask and uh compute a loss over
the targets of test points
so um to break this down a bit further
and point out some of the cool cool
parts of it here um the thing that's
highlighted right now on the far right
is the the term uh relating to the
features it's the feature masking
basically we find that this has a nice
regularizing effect um more or less the
model can now predict anywhere it makes
the task a bit harder and introduces
some more supervision and we found in an
ablation for the tabular data sets that
it helped for eight of 10 of those
um and then there's this other term
which is kind of interesting it's
the stochastic target masking and the
idea is that
you're actually going to have some
training targets
unmasked to the model
at input at training time
which means that the npt can learn to
predict the masked targets of certain
training data points using
the targets of other training data
points as well as all of the training
features
and so that means you don't actually
need to memorize a mapping
between training inputs and outputs in
your parameters you can instead devote
the representational capacity of the
model to learn functions that use other
training features and targets as input
so this is kind of getting into the idea
of this sort of like learn k n idea um
you know obviously we can be learn more
complex
relational lookups and those sorts of
things from this but you can imagine one
such
case being
we have a bunch of test data points
coming in
we're going to look at their features
and use that to assign them to clusters
of training data points and then our
prediction for those points is just
going to be an interpolation of the
training targets in that respective
cluster that's like an example of
something that this mechanism lets uh
npts learn
all right uh so if there's any questions
uh we can take them now otherwise
i'm happy to take them in the the
discussion or something
all right
um so let's discuss yeah yeah go for it
um curious when you're using the entire
data set um
that limit the type of data sets you can
use because of the size
yeah so in practice we do random mini
batching um
to as an approximation so the idea is
just um you know if you have a
reasonably large mini batch uh you're
going to benefit a bit from still having
kind of this this lookup ability because
if your reasonable number of classes
probably you're going to be able to
learn some you know interesting mappings
based on features and targets um amongst
those classes we found in practice that
uh you know and we'll get into this a
little bit but um
we do actually indeed learn
um to use uh relationships between data
points on prediction for data sets where
we're doing mini batching
um and we also didn't necessarily find
that you need like a ludicrously large
batch size for this to be a thing
um
but i do think it's just a this is an in
general an important point and it's one
that points us towards looking into say
um you know sparse transformers
literature for trying to expand to some
larger uh data sets without having the
mini-batching assumption
great thank you uh if i can add a number
to that um we can
without mini batching accommodate data
sets of around like 8 000 points or so
so that that already accounts for
a fair proportion i would say of the
tabular data sets out there but we also
do data sets with 11 million points
where obviously we then resort to mini
purchasing so it's very good to have
like an idea of the size that we're
talking about
i'm curious on that uh i mean it's
pretty exciting
i feel like you don't normally hear
about
transformers being applied to data sets
of size 8000
um
i'm curious and we could talk about this
sort of later once we've covered the
other material if you found that sample
efficiency is one of the key gains here
um or just experience working on small
data sets of transformers generally and
yeah but but i'll happy to put the
answer to that until after
yeah i think that'd be that'd be really
nice to talk about a bit um and it was
something that in general i guess i'd
say was surprising to us in terms of how
robust npts were on small data sets and
how we surprisingly didn't have to tune
a terrible number of parameters but we
can get into details
in a bit
awesome
so to get into the experiments
um
we focused a lot on tabular data
because it's a very general setting
and it's also notoriously challenging
for deep learning so we know
you know tree based boosting methods
stuff like xg boost
is is very dominant and this is also a
very relevant domain to i think people
in industry and that sort of thing so we
were excited about the idea of trying to
do better on this um so we chose a broad
selection of data sets varying across
a few different dimensions um you know
as we mentioned you know on the order of
all hundreds to tens of millions of
instances um
broad range in the number of features in
the composition of features in terms of
being categorical or continuous um
various types of tasks binary or
multi-class classification as well as
regression and like i said the bass
lines were kind of the usual suspects
for tabular uh data xg boost cad boost
light gbm tuned mlps
and tabnet which is a transformer
architecture for tabular data
so uh to get into the results here i'm
showing the average rank uh for the
various subtasks um we did well in terms
of rank-wise performance against methods
like catboost and xgboost which are
designed specifically for tabular data
and um in fact we find that npt is the
top performer on four of the 10 of these
data sets
um on image data
i mentioned that we used a cnn encoder
and with that we were performing well on
c410
and we also think that you know in
general like with um let's say new work
on image transformers on small data this
can probably just be done with linear
patching um and so this kind of the
manner in which you're embedding things
is probably uh not the key
neil if i can jump in with two questions
uh can you go back two slides first
one is just a small minor point uh one
back one more please
thank you uh here are the features 50
plus what does plus mean here
i'll have to double check what the exact
number is i'm pretty sure it's probably
around 50 i would guess like
all right so the 50 is really an order
of it's it's not like 150 or 5 000.
yes yeah i mean i i i'll double check
for you or you can check with the the
metadata statistics at the end of the
paper um but no it wasn't like uh you
know arbitrarily large i would say
though um
you know we did these ablations on
whether or not we actually need um
attention between attributes we did find
that this ended up benefiting us uh but
you could perhaps do um kind of in a
say just an mlp embedding
in that dimension and go to like a
relatively small number of hidden
dimensions and fit uh kind of an
arbitrary number of features
um
so i i think that uh yeah if you if you
kind of relax the necessity of attention
between attributes you can probably
scale out at least that dimension quite
a lot okay and then my second question
if you could go forward one slide
ah thank you uh here i'm not sure i i
quite caught what is it four of ten data
sets two of ten data sets and four of
ten mean
uh this is of the of all the tabular
data sets that we had so oh so
classification is for i see okay
all right yeah exactly
awesome
any other questions
the the standard errors here because i
mean there's like there's just 10 data
sets right
yeah correct 10 10 total tabular data
sets yeah but these are ranked images
yeah these are these are rank wise
performance correct
okay i'm just
missing
how the
where the uncertainty comes from in this
case
yeah average averaged over four of ten
data sets the rank
um so for for each particular data set
we have a rank of all the different
methods then we take the average and the
um variance
of the
of the rankings within each of the um
types of tasks within binary
classification within multi-class et
cetera
we also if you're curious um you know
have have the full results in the paper
yeah thank you
uh we also have a couple of questions
more there's some more questions yeah
hey yeah thanks i guess i just found it
a little surprising that the
worst performer was
k n given that it's also non-parametric
um i guess could you comment on that and
it is
yeah is it that there's something like
intrinsic to the npt that makes it just
exceptional far beyond other
non-parametric methods or
um yeah why why why is it that k n
performs the worst here
well i i suppose ultimately k n is is
still a relatively naive predictive
method and that um you know it might
just be predicting based on kind of
cluster means so
uh
for example um you know i think this is
probably universally true for all the
data sets but there's probably some
amount of kind of
additional reasoning that needs to occur
over the features at least to basic
level so for example like one of the
data sets is this poker hand data set
where it's like a mapping between all of
the different hands you have in poker
and what like they're commonly known to
people like full houses or whatever so
this this requires some amount of
reasoning over the features to be able
to group things together
um
so just taking like the cluster means of
the featurization of those different um
you know hands is likely not going to
give you a great predictive function
um
whereas npt's can kind of do the classic
thing where say you have an mlp type of
thing over the features or like a you
know tree type of thing over the
features you can learn some sort of
complex embedding but then you also can
do um some non-parametric sort of
prediction uh based on say like clusters
of embeddings
yeah that makes sense i guess what if
what if you used
pre-trained embeddings from
a stack of encoders as as your vector
representation for the k n
how do you think that would perform
compared to the rest of the crowd yeah
yeah so this is like um i mean this idea
is kind of like deep kernel learning or
like um
yeah i believe it is deep kernel
learning is basically you use an mlp
independently um
so you learn an mlp on each uh input
data point and then you apply a gp over
all the representations of those so you
get this sort of like complex embedding
and then the
lookups the key difference between that
type of idea and npt's is that we also
learn the relationships between the data
points themselves because we use this
parametric attention mechanism to learn
the relationship so we're not just
learning like and embedding
independently
um we're basically back propagating
through the entire process learning the
ways in which we would try to embed this
but also the the ways that say the
lookup would occur
and essentially the the relationships at
a that could potentially be kind of
higher order as well
okay cool um wait did you not have one
more one more follow-up or
oh yeah go for it cool yeah thanks um so
i guess then if if the advantage of npt
has to do with sort of the relationships
between data points um
then what if you you know took the
uh took the let's say you know encoder
representations
and then
you pass that as input say for the
you know 10 nearest neighbors
along with like some
other like uh
input representation and sort of had
this like weighted average uh like
attention style where you you weighted
the
uh the vectors
of the
nearest neighbors based on the attention
weights between those uh input data
points and then like the supplied input
data point
and then like pass that as as you know
the the
vector uh to like the final prediction
layer like is do you think that captures
some amount of the relationship or or is
that that off base
so i i think the nice part like and
really what our idea is behind this
whole thing is just
these sorts of instances where um
certain fixed kernels would perform
particularly well in tasks is like kind
of an annoyance and like ultimately like
tuning a lot of these types of things or
trying to derive the predictive methods
that might make a lot of sense for a
given situation kind of stinks and
ideally you'd want to just back
propagate on a data set and kind of
learn these relationships yourself so i
actually would be really interested to
see if we can come up with some
synthetic experiments that have these
sort of like very particular k n like
predictive mechanisms and just see if we
can learn precisely those and get uh you
know zero error uh with npts and in fact
like we'll get into this a little bit
with uh some of the interventional
experiments we do we have like
kind of precise lookup functions that
npt's end up being able to learn so we
can learn interesting relational
functions
cool yeah thanks a lot appreciate it
cool
all right we have one more question from
yes
i just wanted to clarify something about
um
basically so at test time you just take
the exact same data set and you just
like add um
like your test examples right and then
you like do the same type of like
masking and
is that how it works
yeah correct
okay got it and i do have one more
question um
that is just because like um i'm i think
i like misunderstood like how
like the effects of your um mpt
objective do you mind going back to that
slide
sure
yeah um can you can you repeat one more
time like what makes this so special
yeah so the
the regularizer on the right over the
features i would think of
uh very similarly to self-supervised
learning with uh just a standard
transformer like you're you're basically
just introducing a lot more supervision
and you're um even if say you're just
doing a supervised objective this is
kind of like some amount of
reconstruction over the features you
learn a more interesting representation
and like
what a regularizing effect um which we
think is interesting but perhaps not as
interesting as this stochastic target
masking this one is unique because
in kind of standard parametric deep
learning you're not going to have an
instance
in your training process where you're
taking
targets as input um and so
basically what happens is
if you have your training data set as
input um whatever you're going to have
some stochastic feature masking stuff
happening on the features
amongst the training targets
you're randomly going to have some of
those unmasked and some of them will
indeed be masked you're going to be back
propagating a loss on the ones that are
masked of course because you know you
don't want your model to have those
available at input if you're going to
actually try to you know back propagate
a loss on it but you can use the other
ones as input and that means you can
learn these kind of like interpolative
functions um so that was like this whole
idea of like being able to kind of like
learn k n
but doesn't that um allow
the model to cheat again
yeah so this is like an interesting
point and actually like subtle so i
think it's it's really worthwhile to to
bring up um so first of all we never
actually back propagate a loss
on something that was visible to the
model at input
and so if if for example the model did
actually end up basically overfitting on
training labels we would not observe the
model's ability to generalize to test
data we don't observe this um so
obviously it seems like this uh kind of
blocking of back propagation on labels
that are visible at in at input to the
to the npt is helping
it could also be possible that
in bird style stochastic masking you
also randomly will flip
uh some labels to be in a different
category um so this is like kind of just
like a random fine print that was
introduced in the the bird masking
text we also do that so it's possible
that that somehow contributes to the
um to that but it's probably uh pretty
likely to just be the fact that we're
not back propagating a loss on something
that's visible
great thanks make sense
i have two more questions if i can jump
in yeah sure sorry can we go to the uh
the metrics the performance the results
slide
okay
i feel like i missed something else i'm
sorry about this so a you are so looking
on the binary classification auroc
um
can you clarify what these numbers mean
are they the auroc
so so this is the um so on each of the
data sets
um so say for a particular binary
classification data set uh we're going
to get a ranking of the methods
um
to repeat this yeah
go forward so so these numbers here are
the the relative ranking across in this
particular case the four data
sets correct yeah ah i see so this these
values are not the aurocs on average
across the data sets
no yeah they're not i mean like
averaging
yeah
everything
might make sense but averaging things
like accuracy and rmse seems like a bad
idea right because
you might have some data sets where
everything has high accuracy or where
rmse means something drastically
different
i see so this these numbers here only
tell us the relative ranking between the
different methods not how well they
actually perform
i mean it tells us how they perform
relative to one another but not how will
they perform
i see okay but that's all in the
appendix we all have we have that
information i see okay i was i was
sitting here confused going like why is
auroc why is the best one the smallest
um an accuracy what is an accuracy of
2.5 anyways okay that makes much more
sense thank you both
awesome
great um so i'll try to speed through
this just in the interest of time um
but the
uh basically thing the thing that you
might be thinking after all these
results is um are we even learning any
data point interactions uh on these real
data sets and so basically we designed
an experiment to figure this out and the
idea is that we're going to disallow npt
from using other data points when
predicting on one of them
if we do that and we observe that npt
actually predicts or performs
significantly worse it is indeed using
these interactions between data points
um a subtle challenge or kind of like an
added bonus we can get from this is that
um ideally we wouldn't actually break
batch statistics so let's say like the
mean of each particular attribute um if
we can find a way to do this experiment
such that we don't break these things um
we can kind of rule out the possibility
that we learn something that's a bit
similar to batch norm
and so the way that we do this is we
basically look at the predictions for
each one of the data points in sequence
so let's say in this case we're looking
at the prediction of the model for this
particular green row and you know it's
going to be predicting in this last
column that has this question mark which
is masked um what we're going to do is
we're going to permute each of the
attributes independently amongst all
other data points except for that one so
the information for that row if it was
kind of just predicting like a classic
parametric deep model is still intact
but the information from all of the
other rows is gone
um so that's why we call this sort of
the corruption experiment
and so we find in general uh when we
perform this experiment uh performance
kind of falls off a cliff for the vast
majority of these methods and i'll note
that um you know the performances uh
between the methods on a lot of these
were fairly close
um and so this is actually indeed pretty
significant so for example on protein uh
we went from being the top performer
amongst all the methods to the worst
performer worse than even like k n or
something like that um
i'll also note that
there's kind of this interesting
behavior where on these data sets like
forest and kik and breast cancer we
actually observe that there's basically
no drop in performance
and we basically see this as kind of an
interesting feature and not necessarily
a bug of the the model which is that if
uh we're back propagating on a given
data set um the model can sort of just
find that it's actually not that
worthwhile to attempt to predict using
some kind of um you know relational
predictive mechanism amongst data points
and can instead just learn to predict
parametrically uh and basically ignore
other data points when it's predicting
on any given one of them
uh and so this probably leads to some
kind of like interesting ideas where
perhaps you could do like post-hoc
pruning or something like that um taking
away the attention between data points
and doing fine tuning let's say
all right um so now i'll hand over to
yannick to talk a bit about learning uh
some interesting relationships
yeah um will you though um i see that
we're at the end of what the time is but
like um i know there's a buffer plan or
something can you
i can go through this experiment we can
have a bit of discussion what's um what
do you guys prefer yeah i think uh
normally what we do is we would sort of
stop the recording at this point and
have an off the record discussion
and uh
i guess the question to ask is does
anyone have any questions at this point
but i think we've basically been
watching questions as they come so i
i personally feel fine just uh
yeah
considering there's a sort of question
throughout
yeah i guess that sounds uh it sounds
good uh janik you can go forward with it
with like with your dog as planned and
yeah we can
later we can see
about the
well amputees perform in real data and
that they do make use of information
from other samples of the input
but we're now going to take this a bit
further and come up with some toy
experiments that
testify the extent to which npts can
learn to look up information from other
roads like the extent to which they can
learn this non-prometric prediction
mechanism
and so specifically what we'll do is
we'll create the following
semi-synthetic dataset
so i want you to focus on a now
yeah so we take one of the tabular data
sets that we've used previously
specifically the project data set but it
doesn't really matter what matters is
that it's a regression data set and so
now what we do is
we
the top half here is the original data
set but the bottom half is a copy of the
original data set where we have unveiled
the true target value
so now npts could learn to use the
tension between data points to achieve
arbitrarily good performance they could
learn to
look up the target values in these
matching duplicate rows and then paste
them back into the that masked out
target value then at test time of course
we put in you know a novel
test data input where this mechanism is
also possible just to make sure that it
hasn't learned to
memorize anything but has actually
learned this correct
relational mechanism
and so what we see is that indeed mpgs
do successfully learn to perform this
lookup so what i'm visualizing here is
attention maps and they very clearly
show that uh let's say when predicting
for this green row here this first green
row what mpgs look at is exactly only
that other green row here
and so
this is really nice um we can further
look at the
kind of the
the pearson correlation between what
npts should predict and what they
actually do predict and so this is 99.9
this is much better than anything you
could achieve with parametric prediction
and so it seems that npt's here can
actually discover this mechanism and
discover here i feel like it's the right
word because npt's could have
as we've seen
just
also continue to predict in parametric
fashion right from each row
independently um
this is really
kind of showing to us that there is this
bias in the model to
learn to predict from other rows and of
course that that is also very attractive
in this setting because it allows you to
achieve arbitrary load loss um in this
setting or as low as you can you can
optimize for it
and so
we we kind of take that to mean that our
you know gradient-based discovery
nonparametrics philosophy seems to make
some sense
and so we can take this a bit further by
performing somewhat of an interventional
experiment that investigates the extent
to which npts have actually learned
a robust uh you know causal mechanism
that's underlying this semi-synthetic
data set
and so
just depending you know this um uh
this
this extra uh this extra column of test
data that is already kind of cool but i
think we can take it a bit further and
actually study if this generalizes um
beyond the data that we see in the
training set or beyond data coming from
this specific distribution and so what
we now do is we intervene
on individual duplicate data points at
test time by varying their target value
so now we only care about the prediction
in a specific row we do this across all
rows but at each time we just throw a
single row what we do is we change the
target value here
that what we're hoping to see is and
then npt just adjusts the prediction as
well right there's a very simple
intervention experiment for us to test
if mpgs have actually learned this
mechanism and to some extent it also
tests robustness because now we're
associating target values with features
that are not part of the training
distribution here
and so what we see is um
that as we adjust
as we adjust these values here the um
this is the kind of the duplicate value
and then we here's the the target value
as we adjust them we can see the the the
correlation stays really really good
it's not quite 99.9 like on average
we're now at 99.6
um but it's still still very very good
and
at this point you might be
uh slightly annoyed with me because you
know standard non-prometric models can
also solve this task right this is a
task that i could solve by nearest
neighbors sure maybe you know i would
have to change the input format a bit
because this is kind of like in a batch
setting and i can just use masks but
most generally nearest neighbor can also
you know it also look up looks up um
different uh input points based on their
features uh nearest ever doesn't learn
to do this i still think it's cool that
we need to learn this because it does
require you know a a decent amount of
you know computational sequences that we
have to learn like match all the
features look up target file you copy it
back and so on but
um it is in fact very easy for us to
complicate this task to a degree such
that
essentially no other model that we know
of uh can consult this um very easily
and so like a really simple thing to do
is just to
add a plus one to all of the duplicate
values
um so now nearest neighbor would look up
the right column at the right row of
course but it would always predict the
wrong target with a plus one on it and
in fact many of the
the models that we're aware of they're
not modeling
the joint distribution over features and
targets what they're modeling is the
traditional distribution of the targets
given the input features and so they
also cannot do this and so for us it's
really not a problem at all um
amputees will just learn to subtract
another one and no problems and sure
this is also still a very synthetic
setting but um i do think uh
i mean i challenge you to come up with
something that amputees can't solve but
the other models can solve i think this
in general this masking mechanism and
the nonprometricity of the approach is
really nice in general and leads to lots
of nice behavior in a variety of
settings
and so with that um i think we can go to
the conclusions which um neil is going
to give you
yeah i think um i mean we can cut out
the
main part here i'll just fast forward
let's look at them
yeah yeah i i was gonna say i think you
got you all get the gist um npt's take
the entire data set as input and they
use self-attention to model complex
relationships between data points um
you know they do
well in experiments on top of their data
as well as image data
we present some of these interventional
experiments to show that they can solve
complex reasoning tasks uh there's some
more experiments in the paper i'd say
that um you know the interesting type of
future work
is um scaling type things so we can uh
you know not having this mini batching
approximation and then also just trying
to expand this to some more interesting
application domain so we talked a little
bit about metal learning but it could
also be things like you know fusha
generalization in general demand
adaptation semi-supervised learning etc
so i think if um if there's some more
questions maybe we can do some more
discussion
um yeah thing sounds good uh great
thanks for the talk i think everyone had
a fun time
um i will just ask some general
questions and then we can have like a
discussion session with uh everyone
after that
uh so i think one thing that i noticed
is like uh
like this like you said like this is
similar to like k ns
and i thought like this seems similar to
like graph neural networks where you can
think like uh each data point is like a
node and then you can think of
everything as a fully connected graph
and you're learning some sort of
attention weight in this graph
uh so this is like a note prediction
task you are kind of doing on this uh
sort of like graph structure
so any comments on that like is it
similar to like neural networks or is it
like
other differences
yeah it's a very good observation yeah i
think there are a lot of similarities to
work done on graph neural networks um if
we want to talk about differences the
differences might be that that we are
kind of assuming a fully connected graph
right um
and so you could maybe also phrase that
as we're discovering the relational
structure whereas graph neural networks
usually assume that it's given
um but that's also not always true and
so there are
a lot of similarities i don't know neil
if there is something specific you would
like to mention go ahead but it's a very
good observation and we also do feel
that that's the case and we've added an
extra section on related work to
graphical networks in the the updated
version of the paper that will be online
soon
got it yeah i i agree with everything
you've said i think that the closest
work from the gnn literature that we
were looking at a little bit was this
neural relational inference paper which
uses messing passage
message passing neural networks to try
to kind of like learn um edges that may
or may not exist and help for like uh
extrapolating um i think positions of
like particles in like a multi-particle
system or something um which is like
kind of a similar idea to us like you
know if you don't have these edges as
given the attention mechanism could kind
of approximate an interesting
relationship amongst uh some interacts
interacting things
i see got it
yeah that's pretty cool um another thing
is like so you mostly look on like
tabular data but can you also like have
other modalities like if you want to do
language or something uh can you still
use uh non-parametric transformers
yeah so i i think uh part of our
motivation for doing tabular was because
we felt like tabular data is in a sense
a generalization of um let's say the
language data for example i mean i guess
there's this these other notions like
that people have brought up like padding
um but ultimately you can think of it as
like a bunch of categorical attributes
um so it is uh it is definitely
generalizable to things like um
sentences and we do uh you know images
um so yeah
so i think actually like
i like part i i always go back and forth
on whether or not i think smaller or
larger data is more interesting for us
so i think small data is really
interesting because we can't just fit
the entire data set into it and
all of this just
works out of the box without any extra
thought but large data is actually also
really interesting because
sure you might have to introduce some
approximative mechanism or some lookup
mechanism because you can't always have
the entire data set
in
but at the same time you are very
explicitly kind of trading off the
compute that you use to look up uh with
the compute that you need to store like
how much how many parameters in gpg are
used for storing
data right there's lots of memorization
happening in these models and we know
that and so maybe we can use the
problems more efficiently to learn
look-up type behavior right that is more
close to this you know neural k n or
whatever so i think these are very
exciting
questions
yeah yeah i'll also be looking forward
to the future works because it seems
like a very good
way to like do one-shot learning kind of
situations so yeah really very
interesting to see that
um okay so
i will stop the recording and we can
have like any other questions